[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne
gellineck guten Abend an einem Abend mit
einem winzigen Hoffnungsstrahl vor dre
Stunden kam die Meldung dass die Hamas
zwei verschleppte am amerikanische
Geiseln aus dem Gazastreifen
freigelassen hat vermittelt offenbar mit
Hilfe von Qatar zwei von über 200
allerdings nur und es bleibt unklar wie
es den vielen anderen entführten geht
gleichzeitig laufen offenbar die
Vorbereitungen für eine israelische
Bodenoffensive weiter außerdem ließ die
Armee heute die Stadt kiriatchmona an
der Grenze zum Libanon Räumen l walpot
berichtet aus Tel
Aviv die Tafel zum Schabbat ist
gerichtet aber die 200 Stühle bleiben
leer in Tel Aviv warten die Familien der
vielen Geiseln in der Hand der Hamas
darunter 20 Kinder und Jugendliche auf
Nachrichten zwischen Hoffen und Bangen
wie aalet saberano die ihren Sohn
Jonathan vermisst die Mehrheit der
entführten sei am Leben meldete die
Armee
heute wir hoffen dass er lebt und
natürlich wollen wir ihn
zurück wir wollen dass er frei kommmt
zusammen mit all den anderen Kindern und
Eltern am Abend die überraschende
einmeldung im Fernsehen Hamas soll eine
amerikanische Mutter und ihre Tochter
Judith und Natalie ranan freigelassen
haben die Geiseln sein in Sicherheit
bestätigt die
Armee die Regierung die Armee und alle
Sicherheitskräfte Israels werden weiter
alle Wege nutzen um die Entführten zu
finden und nach Hause zu
bringen Israels Armee bere unterdessen
weiter mit Luftangriffen im Gazastreifen
eine mögliche Bodenoffensive vor dabei
wurde auch ein Kirchengebäude in Gaza
Stadt getroffen nach palästinensischen
Angaben kamen 17 Menschen ums Leben die
Armee räumte ein ein Teil der Kirche sei
beim Angriff auf ein Hamas
Kommandozentrum beschädigt worden
militärisch angespannt auch die Lage im
Norden Israels die libanesische
Terrororganisation Hisbollah liefert
sich hier seit Tagen Feuergefechte mit
der isischen Armee Israel rief die
Bewohner entlang der Grenze auf sich in
Sicherheit zu
bringen ich habe Todesangst ich bin
allein erziehend und ich wurde noch
nicht evakuiert ich warte seit drei
Tagen ich habe
Todesangst verhindern dass sich der
Konflikt ausweitet eines der Anliegen
von Außenministerin berärburg gestern in
am Mann heute in telaviv bevor sie nach
Beirut und Kairo
weiterreist wollen verhindern dass die
ganze Region ins Chaos stürzt deshalb
bin ich ganz klar an all diesen Orten in
meinen Botschaften hisbolla darf den
Libanon nicht mit in diesen Konflikt
hineinziehen an der Grenze zu Ägypten
warteten unterdessen auch heute
hunderttausende Flüchtlinge im
Gazastreifen auf die dringend benötigte
Hilfe vergeblich auch un Generalsekretär
guteres persönlich angereist konnte noch
keinen Durchbruch erzielen
diese Lastwagen sind eine Lebensader sie
sind der Unterschied zwischen Leben und
Tod für so viele Menschen in
Gaza morgen so heißt es könnte bei einer
Gipfelkonferenz in Ciro die Öffnung der
Grenze für Hilfsgüter verkündet
werden und aus Israel ist uns auch heute
Abend unser Korrespondent Michael
bwerunge zugeschaltet Michael die
Meldung von der Freilassung zweier
amerikanischer Geisel die Macht Geiseln
die Macht Hoffnung heute Abend auch für
die anderen
Geiseln mit aller Vorsicht gesprochen
möglicherweise ja denn es scheinen die
Dinge in Bewegung zu geraten da ist zum
einen die Tatsache dass überhaupt die
Freilassung von zwei Geisen erreicht
werden konnte offenbar auf Vermittlung
qatars Qatar sagt es werde weiter daran
arbeiten auch alle anderen zivilen
Geisel also nicht die Soldaten zu
befreien dann gibt es gerade die
erstaunliche Meldung dass auch die Hamas
sagt wir sind verhandlungsbereit
allerdings unter bestimmten Bedingungen
unter der Einhaltung bestimmter
Sicherheitsbedingungen was damit gemeint
ist ist noch
unklar dann gibt es die Konferenz morgen
in Kairo wo viele Staats und
Regierungschefs und viele Vertreter
anderer Staaten zusammenkommen es ist zu
hören dass viele Staaten Druck auf
Israel ausüben die anstehende
Bodenoffensive zumindest weiter noch zu
verschieben das würde Raum für
Verhandlungen öffnen um weitere Geiseln
zu befreien allerdings ganz aufhalten
lassen wird sich diese Bodenoffensive
insgesamt nicht nach einer Umfrage von
heute sind fast zwei Drittel aller
Israelis dafür dass diese Bodenoffensive
durchgeführt wird also heute abend
vorsichtige Hoffnungsschimmer danke
Michael nach
Israel noch vor ein paar Wochen gingen
hunderttausende Israelis fast jedes
Wochenende auf die Straße um gegen die
sogenannte Justizreform von
Premierminister Netanyahu zu
protestieren nach dem Terror der Hamas
ist diese Auseinandersetzung in den
Hintergrund getreten aber die
whatsapp-gruppen in denen sich die
Protestler organisiert hatten die gibt
es immer noch und sind jetzt kurzerhand
umfunktioniert worden zu einem Netzwerk
von Helfern freiwillige unterstützen
Menschen die ihr zu Hause verlassen
mussten besorgen Lebensmittel und melken
manchmal sogar Kühe wenn es nötig ist
die
ist riesig Alisa jung hat eine Helferin
begleitet sie ist unterwegs im Westen
von telaviv ires Ginsburg kümmert sich
um geflüchtete
Israelis wir fahren jetzt nach Tomer das
ist die nächste Nachbarschaft zu Israels
größtem Krankenhaus denn in der Familie
die dort in einer Wohnung untergebracht
ist ist die Mutter schwanger im ne Monat
deshalb haben wir sie dort
untergebracht
ein Plüschhund für die Kinder ein
Wasserkocher ihres bringt vorbei was
Familie Bar zurücklassen musste sie sind
geflohen aus nitivot nur zwei Orte
weiter hat die Hamas im kibutzberi
etliche Menschen getötet und
entführt die Kinder sind unter den Tisch
gekrochen eines meiner Kinder hatte so
Angst dass sie am Tag des Angriffs
nichts gegessen hat und auch mehrere
Tage danach
nicht
sobald sie konnten stiegen sie ins Auto
und verließen ihr
zuuhause als wir gefahren sind habe ich
immer auf der Straße hin und her
geschaut ich hatte so Angst ich bin
schwanger und habe es in meinem Bauch
gespürt ich war
nervös war sehr
schwer Nachbarn haben partnenschaften
für die neuankommenden Familien gebildet
sammeln hier alles was man braucht von
Lebensmitteln bis Babydecken für die
geflüchteten Menschen aus dem Süden und
Norden Israels und vermitteln sie in
leerstehende
Wohnungen vor anderthalb Wochen konnten
wir uns nicht vorstellen dass wir zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt bereits für 40
Familien eine Bleibe gefunden haben
würden
in der ganzen Stadt sind private
hilfsinitiativen entstanden 15000
freiwillige organisieren hier auf dem
Messegelände Nothilfe für ganz Israel
die Leute flüchteten von deren Häusern
und die hatten keine an Möglichkeit
irgendetwas mitzunehmen wann und ob die
Familien wieder zurückkehren können ist
unklar ich glaube nicht
dass sie hofft trotzdem auf etwas R für
die Kinder und ihr
Baby wenn es überhaupt Gewinner gibt in
diesem Konflikt dann sitzen sie in
Moskau und in Teran in Moskau weil die
Aufmerksamkeit gerade vom russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine abgelenkt
ist und in Teran weil die mullas die
Terrorattacken der Hamas als deutliches
Zeichen für das Zitat nahende Ende des
Erzfeindes Israel sehen die ayatollas
versorgen die Hamas mit Raketen und
drohen unverhohen auf Seiten der
Terrororganisation in den Konflikt
einzugreifen der Westen dagegen warnt
tearan seit Tagen vor dem Sprung auf das
trittbett trittbett des Terrors wie
analena berbock heute formulierte noch
so scheint es haben die mullas nicht
entschieden Kamran safjarian
berichtet ein marzialisches
propagandavideo der iranischen
revolutionsgarten es soll einen Angriff
auf die israelische Atomanlage diona
simulieren eine Blaupause auch für einen
Krieg gegen
Israel Irans Außenminister bemühte sich
zuletzt seine Verbündeten gegen Israel
einzuschwören syriens Machthaber Assad
hboll Chef nasrala und Hamas Chef han
und er droht Israel
offen wenn die Kriegsverbrechen des
kindertötenden Regimes Israels
weiterehen wird alles möglich
sein die Führer des Widerstands haben
mir deutlich klar gemacht dass sie
jederzeit zu einem Krieg mit den
zionistischen Besatzern bereit
sind der Widerstand damit sind Länder
gemeint mit denen Iran in seinem Hass
gegen Israel Allianzen aufgebaut hat
schiitische Milizen im Irak dem Assad
regim in Syrien und der hisbolla Miliz
im Libanon Iran könnte so jederzeit
Fronten gegen Israel aufmachen ich
glaube die Absicht des Iran in dieser
Hinsicht ist es eine mögliche
Bodenoffensive der Israelis in Gase
abzuschrecken mit Hilfe der Drohung dass
die hisboll intervenieren könnte dass
eine oder mehrere weitere Fronten
aufgemacht werden gegen Israel und die
Frage ist ob man letztendlich der hboll
den Befehl erteilt einzugreifen sollten
die Israelis Bodenoffensive auch
wirklich starten dann droht Israel
größte Gefahr durch den unmittelbaren
Nachbar der hisbolla Miliz im Libanon
und ihrem Waffenarsenal sollte es zu ein
Intervention der hisbolla kommen dann
hätte das schwerwiegende Konsequenzen
für Israel es würde sich zu einem zwei
frontenkrieg ausweiten mit einer
Gruppierung die deutlich deutlich
stärker ist als die Hamas man geht davon
aus dass hisbolla bis 150 000 oder sogar
200 000 Raketen besitzt darunter
antischiffsraketen Raketen mit
präzisionssteuerung die gezielt
militärische Ziele und kritische
Infrastruktur in Israel angreifen
könnten ein Szenario für dass die USA
bereits Flugzeugträger in die Region
entsandt haben dennoch Israel ist
geschwächt seine Allianz mit Irans
Rivalen Saudi-Arabien liegt auf Eis Iran
kann seine Vormachtstellung am Golf
ausbauen und auch seine bombenpläne
weiterentwickeln außenpolitisch hat Iran
in den letzten Monaten von der Weltlage
profitiert insgesamt würde ich
argumentieren dass sich die strategische
Position der Iraner verbessert hat die
große Frage ist jetzt ob sie die neue
Weltlage dazu nutzen sich atomar zu
bewaffnen oder
nicht Atomwaffen in den Händen der
mullas es wäre ein Albtraum für Israel
und für die ganze
Region Bundespräsident Steinmeier traf
sich heute mit Angehörigen von Menschen
die von den Hamas Terroristen in den
Gazastreifen verschleppt wurden die
deutsche Regierung setze sich mit aller
Kraft für deren Freilassung ein
versprach er den Familien der Geiseln
und appellierte an alle deutschen
jüdisches Leben zu schützen sei
Bürgerpflicht die Innenministerin
präsentierte passend dazu Zahlen zu
antisemitischen Vorfällen und damit
beginnen die Nachrichten von Heinz Wolf
seit dem Terrorangriff der Hamas auf
Israel sind in Deutschland nach
vorläufigen Zahlen bislang mehr als 1100
Straftaten in diesem Kontext registriert
worden bundesinnenministerin fäer sagte
es gebe keinerlei Toleranz für
antisemitische und Israel feindliche
Hetze und keinerlei Toleranz für Gewalt
alle polizeilichen Möglichkeiten müssen
genutzt und hart eingeschritten werden
wenn der Terror der Hamas verherrlicht
werde der Bundesrat hat Israel seine
volle Solidarität zugesichert die
Angriffe der Hamas verurteilten die
Länder als Akt der Barberei und des
Terrors mit einer Schweigeminute zu
Beginn hat der Bundesrat an die Opfer
der Angriffe erinnert an der Sitzung
nahm auch der israelische Botschafter
Ron prosor
teil
der Bundesrat hat heute auch eine Reihe
von Beschlüssen gefasst so sollen
Bürgergeld und Sozialhilfe wie in einer
Verordnung der Bundesregierung
vorgesehen um rund 12% erhöht werden ab
dem kommenden Jahr sollen demnach etwa
alleinstehende
53 € im Monat erhalten 61 mehr als
bisher die ungewöhnlich hohe Steigerung
ist auf die derzeitige Inflation und
steigende Nettolöhne zurückzuführen die
in die Berechnung mit
einfließen
Bundestag und Bundesrat haben auch
mehrere Reformen im Verkehrssektor
verabschiedet die lkwmaut wird neu
gestaltet ab Dezember wird erstmals der
CO2 Ausstoß berücksichtigt ab Juli
2024 wird die Maut für lastastwagen ab
mehr als 3,5 statt wie bisher 7,5 Tonnen
gelten die zusätzlichen Mittel sind fürs
Fernstraßen und fürs Schienennetz
vorgesehen und gleichzeitig sollen
Planungsverfahren und Genehmigungen für
neue Projekte deutlich vereinfacht
werden die Regierung ist ganz schön
gerupft worden in den Landtagswahlen von
Hessen und Bayern vor zwei Wochen die
ampelparteien versuchten sich danach in
Demut einige mehr andere weniger fdpchef
Lindner kündigte an die Regierungsarbeit
kritisch prüfen zu wollen z.B heute
Nachmittag im
Koalitionsausschuss da saßen die
ampelchefs und die Fraktionsspitzen mit
dem Kanzler zusammen die die Themenliste
überlang Flüchtlingspolitik und ihre
Finanzierung Streit über einen
verbilligten Strompreis für die
Industrie und dann ist da noch der
Nahostkonflikt dass die Ampel weniger
streiten und mehr liefern muss
unterstreichen auch die frischen Zahlen
des ZDF
politbarometers demnach verlieren alle
drei Regierungsparteien an Zustimmung
SPD -2% auf 15 grüne -2 auf 14 und die
FDP -1 auf 5% profitieren kann davon die
Union 4% Plus auf
30%. würde diesen Sonntag also gewählt
wäre die ampelmehrheit futsch der Druck
auf die Koalition
wächst Theo K in Berlin hat das Treffen
der ampelaner für uns beobachtet Theo
angesichts der Umfragewerte müsste die
Koalition sich doch jetzt mal richtig
zusammenraufen welche Anzeichen gibt es
dafür dass das diesmal klappt also
Anzeichen dafür dass es klappt wäre
wahrscheinlich verwegen zu sagen aber
Anzeichen dafür dass man es versucht das
ja das heutige koalitionsgespräch
bezeichneten Teilnehmer eben als
intensiv und ernsthaft man hatte sich in
diesem Kreis ja immerhin drei Monate
nicht gesehen und zuletzt hatte der FDP
Generalsekretär die Grünen als
Sicherheitsrisiko fürs Land bezeichnet
das Kreisen der so gescholtenen grünen
jedenfalls wurde positiv vermerkt dass
sich trotz der ja auch für die FDP
schwierigen landtagswahlergebnisse die
Tonlage offensichtlich deutlich
verbessert hat heute Abend so es zu
hören wurde dann neben narost vor allem
über die vom Wähler empfundenen
ampelfizite gesprochen also Migration
und die wirtschaftliche Lage und bei
letzterem sucht die Ampel nach Antworten
für eine Trendwende das klingt nach wir
wollen uns bemühen aber viel mehr war es
auch noch nicht und ist man sich denn
inhtlich bei der Frage
Flüchtlingspolitik und deren
Finanzierung irgendwie näher gekommen
also auf das weitergekommen und näher
gekommen gibt zwei ganz klare
Perspektiven unterschiedliche
Perspektiven die eine die der Parteien
besagt dass man dem Kanzler jetzt beien
Freiheit zugestanden habe um bei der
Zuwanderung ein Paket zu verhandeln und
zu Ende zu schnüren die Sicht des
Kanzleramts die scheint eher zu sein
dass Olaf Scholz sich nach den
problematischen landtagswahlergebnissen
die bayenfreiheit selbst genommen hat
und die anderen sich jetzt quasi hinter
den Zug werfen wie dem auch sei der
Kanzler hat heute in der neuen Ausgabe
des SPIEGEL sehr deutliche Töne zur
Zuwanderung gewählt er sagt wir müssen
endlich im großen Stil abschieben und er
sagt es kommen zu viele also der Ton ist
deutlich schärfer geworden wenn man sich
aber die Maßnahmen anschaut die er im
Interview anführt dann sind die alle
schon bekannt und werden die Lage
kurzfristig nicht verändern aber Olaf
Scholz hat mit dem Satz wir müssen
endlich im großen Stil abschieben jetzt
Erwartungen geweckt an denen wird man
ihn künftig messen können danke Theo mit
dem Kanzler und der Bein Freiheit und
den neuen Tönen in unser
Hauptstadtstudio nach Berlin und wir
machen hier weiter mit den Nachrichten
zunächst aus der Wirtschaft und die hat
Heinz Wolf das Statistische Bundesamt
verzeichnet einen rekordrückgang bei den
Erzeugerpreisen gewerblicher Produkte
sie viielen im September im Vergleich
zum Vorjahr um durchschnittlich
14,7% und das führt zur Frage an Frank
betmann was sich daraus ablesen lässt
wie es mit der Inflation weitergeht na
sind grundsätzlich gute Nachrichten der
Preisdruck lässt weiter nach und das
dürfte sich in den kommenden Wochen und
Monaten fortsetzen denn auf breiter
Front fallen die Preise noch längst
nicht vor allem die Energiepreise also
die für stromheizöl Gas und Sprit haben
auf jahricht bereits deutlich
nachgegeben teurer als vor einem Jahr
aber bleiben beispielsweise
Nahrungsmittel besonders bei Zucker
verarbeiteten Kartoffeln oder Obst und
gemüseerzeugnissen warten die
Konsumenten noch darauf dass es wieder
billiger wird die Erzeugerpreise haben
vor allem des deswegen eine wichtige
Signalwirkung weil sie frühzeitig
anzeigen wie sich die Preise an der
Ladentheke entwickeln könnten muss man
sagen denn selten werden die preissung
Senkungen eins zu ein an die Verbraucher
weitergegeben und noch etwas dämpft die
Euphorie ein Risiko für den
inflationsausblick bleibt allerdings der
Krieg in Nahost sagt Sebastian dulien
vom Institut für Makroökonomie und
Konjunkturforschung
IMK sollte sich der Konflikt auf die
erdölländer ausweiten dann dürften die
Ölpreise umgehend nach oben schießen und
die teurerung wieder anfachen auch der
DAX bleibt vorsichtig und schließt auf
dem tiefsten Stand seit 7 Monaten Frank
betmann vielen
dankne es gibt aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor
orkanartigen Böhen in Teilen von
Schleswig-Holstein und damit kommen wir
auch zur Hochwassersituation an der
Ostseeküste in Mecklenburg Vorpommern
und Schleswig-Holstein dort sorgt seit
dem morgen eine Sturmflut unter anderem
für überflutete Straßen und umgestürzte
Bäume mindestens ein Mensch kam ums
Leben besonders betroffen sind die
Küstenstreifen schleswig- Holsteins wie
hier in Kiel peitschten hohe Wellen an
und über die Ufer bis in die Nacht
könnten die Wasserstände weitersteigen
in flenszburg wurden am Abend 2,22 m
übermittlerem Hochwasser und damit der
höchste Wasserstand seit mehr als 100
Jahren
erreicht kann man aus der Geschichte
eines mit Läufers in der Nazizeit eines
Filmregisseurs der zur falschen Zeit aus
Hollywood nach Deutschland kommt kann
man daraus einen Roman machen der schwer
und gleichzeitig brüllend komisch ist
man kann wenn man Daniel Killmann heißt
sein neues Buch Lichtspiel erzählt das
Leben des in den 20er Jahren
weltberühmten Regisseurs Georg Wilhelm
Papst anhand von Waren und von
erfundenen Begebenheiten ein Künstler
der vom Immigranten zum Handlanger der
Nazis wird unser Kritiker Claudio
Armbruster findet dieser Roman ist
großes
Kino so oft ist do alles eine Frage der
Perspektive und er entscheidet sich gern
für die ungewöhnliche wir treffen Daniel
Kehlmann im Berliner Museum für Film und
Fernsehen denn in seinem neuen Roman
geht es um den deutschen Film im
Nationalsozialismus schwerer Stoff also
und er verspürt wie so oft bei zu großem
Ernst die Neigung zur Karikatur es gibt
gar kein Thema das so düster ist dass
man nicht davon mit einer gewissen Form
von entweder leichtem aber oder auch
schon groteskem Humor erzählen kann man
kann glaube ich ohne Humor Gedichte
schreiben das meine ich jetzt nicht
negativ oder vielleicht sogar
Theaterstücke aber erzählen ist
immer ein Versuch die Kompliziertheit
der Dinge zu sehen aber auch die
Lächerlichkeit der Dinge die groß und k
also das heißt man kann auch vom dritten
Reich komisch erzählen das Dritte Reich
war ein unendlich furchtbar es war aber
auch unendlich lächerlich und davon darf
man erzählen glaube ich Lichtspiel heißt
der Roman hauptfigur ist der deutsche
Regisseur Georg Wilhelm Papst der 1925
Greta Garbo zum Weltstar machte mit
seinem Film die freudlose Gasse reale
Figuren und Ereignisse also literarisch
veredelt von Daniel kehmann da ist ein
Bild da da ist sieht man ihn der Mann
mit der der etwas stärker gebaute Mann
mit der Brille und der
Halbglatze das war er er war mal ein
sehr berühmter Regisseur er war einer
der berühmtesten stummfilmregisseure der
Welt und hat diese einzigartige
rätselhafte Geschichte Papst war in
Hollywood als Emigrant er hat dort
gearbeitet er konnte Filme drehen und
ist dann zurückgegangen ins dritte Reich
ins Nazireich und hat für Göbbels Filme
gedreht und das finde ich unendlich
verwirrend faszinierend und einfach
erzählenswert nach seinen historischen
Bestsellern die Vermessung der Welt und
til erweckte also wieder die deutsche
Vergangenheit zum Leben 480 Seiten prall
gefüllt mit Wortwitz und vor allem aber
einer fesselnden Geschichte bei seiner
Rückkehr war er auf Verbrecher gefasst
gewesen auf verrote Menschen und
entkommene Nazis nicht gefasst gewesen
war er auf all die verschmitzten Mädchen
die Brillantine feuchten Jungmänner die
verschrobenen Onkels und tief unlustigen
Witzbolde die auf einmal die deutschen
Filme bevölkerten als wäre das ganze
Land wahnsinnig geworden überall
verschwieg man es aber in den Filmen sah
man es
unverstellt
das wäre cool wenn ihr das sendet na
dann senden wir das Kehlmanns Lichtspiel
ist ein und das Wortspiel muss jetzt
kommen Lichtblick in diesem
Bücherherbst und wir geben jetzt ab an
Matthias fornof der z.B weiß was die
Deutschen über die mögliche
Bodenoffensive der israelischen Armee
denken das ZDF Politbarometer mit
brandneuen
zahlen
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer viele Ideen große Pläne
so sind SPD Grüne und FDP vor knapp 2we
Jahren ins Abenteuer Ampel gestartet
Olaf Scholz versprach das Land zu
modernisieren und dann endloser Streit
wenig Verlässlichkeit zu ungleich die
Partner zu häufig die Krisen die
Unzufriedenheit mit dem schwierigen
Dreierbündnis hat einen neuen
Höchststand
erreicht dass die Bundesregierung ihre
Arbeit gut macht finden nur noch 32%.
beinah doppelt so viele sagen die Ampel
arbeitet schlecht würde eine
unionsgeführte Regierung es besser
machen ein knappes Drittel vermutet ja
49% würden keinen Unterschied erwarten
dass es dann schlechter liefe sagen
15%.
trotzdem von der Schwäche der Ampel
profitiert die Union im Vergleich zu
unserer letzten Umfrage die noch vor den
Landtagswahlen in Bayern und Hessen lag
deutlich wenn am nächsten Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre kenme die SPD auf
15%
-2 CDU CSU 30 + 4 deutlich stärker die
Grünen
14-2 FDP
5-1 AFD 21 die Linke 5ünf Freie Wähler
3% alle drei
unverändert für SPD und Grüne ihre
schlechtesten Werte seit
Regierungsantritt die Ampel kämmen nur
noch auf ein Drittel der Stimmen damit
wären nur noch Dreier Bündnisse unter
Führung der CDU CSU möglich und
politisch
denkbar schauen wir auf unsere Top 10
also die Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung die negativ
bewertete Regierungsarbeit schlägt auch
hier durch die Protagonisten der Ampel
rutschen ab die Köpfe der Union steigen
auf auf der Skala von plus5 bis -5 ist
Alis Weidel Schlusslicht - 2,4
verbessert vorletzte SAR Wagenknecht
-1,1 etwas besser Robert
habck berb Christian Lindner jeweils
-0,5 Karl latorbach -0,4 alle deutlich
schlechter davor Friedrich märz - 0,3
deutlich verbessert Olaf Scholz -0,2 büß
stark ein Markus Söder 0,1 deutlich
verbessert und mit Abstand vorn
weiterhin Boris Pistorius 1,6
verschlechtert auch wenn die Union die
kanzlerkandidatenfrage erst nächsten
Spätsommer beantworten will erste
Diskussionen und Rangeleien sind schon
da größte Chance auf ein gutes
Bundestagswahlergebnis hätte die CDU CSU
mit dem bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten
Markus Söder sagen 31% der
Unionsanhänger 27 % trauen das Hendrik
wüst zu dem Ministerpräsidenten von
Nordrhein-Westfalen für 23% der eigenen
Anhänger ist CDU Chef Friedrich März der
aussichtsreichste Kandidat abgeschlagen
Daniel Günther Ministerpräsident in
schliwig Holstein 5%
Zustimmung so wie die Unionsanhänger
sehen das mehr oder weniger auch alle
Befragten ein Thema steht für die
deutschen ganz weit oben Flucht Asyl und
Migration kann Deutschland die vielen
Flüchtlinge die aus Krisengebieten zu
uns kommen
verkraften ein Drittel sagt ja zwei
Drittel meinen nein im Vergleich zum
März dieses Jahres hat sich die Stimmung
deutlich gewandelt eine knappe Mehrheit
sagte damals ja Deutschland verkraftet
das die Bundesregierung plant Maßnahmen
um abgelehnte Asylbewerber leichter
abschieben zu können die Mehrheit der
Befragten glaubt allerdings nicht dass
es dadurch zu deutlich mehr
Rückführungen kommen wird das
Flüchtlinge und Asylbewerber bei uns in
Zukunft schneller eine Arbeitserlaubnis
bekommen finden fast alle befragten gut
wohl auch angesichts der vielen offenen
Stellen im
Land zum Schluss ein Blick in den Nahen
Osten und auf die Folgen des
beispiellosen terrorangriffs der Hamas
die israelische Führung will die Hamas
so schwächen dass von ihr keine Gefahr
mehr für Israel ausgeht kann das
gelingen 18% meinen ja gut zwei Drittel
glauben nicht dass das Israel gelingen
wird hoffen wir dass die
krisendiplomatie an der sich auch die
deutsche Regierung intensiv beteiligt
Eskalationen und weiteres Leid
verhindern
kann das war unser Bericht über die
Stimmung im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite
165 in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de vielen Dank für
Ihr Interesse das nächste Politbarometer
gibt's dann am 10 November hier folgt
jetzt das Wetter danach geht's weiter
mit der heutehow einen schönen Abend auf
Wiedersehen
guten Abend das Tief das für den
kräftigen Wind an der Küste
verantwortlich war hat inzwischen hier
schon die Nordsee erreicht aber jetzt
kommt ein weiteres Tief hinterher das
bringt noch mal kräftigen Regen mit sie
sehen aber auch wie der heftige Wind
sich nach Norden verabschiedet und immer
mehr verschwindet heute Abend und in der
ersten Nachthälfte allerdings haben wir
es noch mit orkanartigen Böhen um 110 km
pro Stunde an den K Küsten von Nord und
Ostsee zu tun und das führt dazu dass
das Ostseewasser nach Westen gedrückt
wird an den Ostküsten hier also gibt es
ein Sturmhochwasser in Flensburg kann
das Wasser 2 m über dem üblichen
Wasserstand auflaufen an der Nordsee
gibt's dagegen eher niedrig Wasser außer
viel Wind gibt's in dieser Nacht eben
auch viel Regen hier im Süden und
Südosten ist zum Teil auch klar da
bildet sich mal Nebel und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 4° morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei 12 bis
20° und besonders im Nordosten wird es
deutlich milder als noch heute der Regen
der Nacht zieht morgen weiter nordwärts
dann wechseln Sonne und Wolken
freundlich miteinander ab der Wind ist
längst nicht mehr so kräftig er kommt
aus südwestlichen Richtungen und noch
eine Spur freundlicher wird dann der
Sonntag bei Höchsttemperaturen von 10
bis 18° und die neue Woche startet recht
freundlich zur Wochenmitte wird's dann
wechselhaft und es bleibt für dann bald
Ende Oktober ausgesprochen mild schönes
Wochenende